in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape with me in the
studio today is dr. Heiner banger from
the email in hospital in billion he's an
expert on complementary medicine and
nutrition welcome to the show dr. Stan
when it comes to osteoporosis how
successful is diet in treating this
condition well it's one of the basics of
course it's not the only condition that
improves osteoporosis or prevents but of
course in sufficient supply of calcium
is important but also of other minerals
fluorite whatever end of especially
vitamin D vitamin D is it enough to take
it via nutrients and eat it or do you
need anything else to get a sufficient
amount of vitamin D well that depends of
course in which part of the words you
live in you can check on your blood
concentration that's a very effective
parameter and then you may have to use a
supplement yes it often happens even
with people that live out outside their
homes for lots of time so should
everybody go and see their GP to get
some blood drawn and take the level of
vitamin D well in first case those large
risk smokers women who get their minna
pause very early and this type of thing
people who have to take certain drugs
and so forth hmm and in your clinic you
offer a new nutritional therapy it's
like an outpatient department for
nutritional therapy so why are you doing
this what kind of conditions can you
treat it's just food well for example
people with rheumatic diseases often
have a lot of profit from certain rules
of diet like more fish or more other
intake of plant-based omega-3 fatty
acids and avoidance of Erika
sonic acid would which is found in
animal food especially and more green
vegetables more fruit they often have
profit from that so we got a lot of
viewers we can't come into your
outpatient department but we got
facebook we got a lot of questions for
this and on our facebook page and lot of
viewers asked us about all these
nutrition things and I just want to try
you to answer some for example Conrad
ruffle from Tanzania wants to know which
food can help to lower the blood sugar
level well of course this is how diet
started with medicine you know with this
problem we know that complex
carbohydrates slow down the resort of
glucose and that's very important to
have flat our curse of glucose in the
blood and that's very efficient for
people with diabetes but also for others
so that's that's very important and then
of course there are some food all
additives you might say like cinnamon
that helped lower the blood glucose
level but you have to take very high
doses so you really have to be a fan of
that and at the moment we don't have an
idea of how to compose a diet that is
optimal to lower blood glucose except
for these few roads that are mentioned
in with a different question from two
parts out of this world dhoni bus from
Australia and Sara I dolly from Dubai
wrote in to ask whether certain foods
can relieve irritable bowel syndrome
well this is of course a problem all
over the world and we have the
impression that it goes along with a
Western diet especially with the
consumption of certain series of certain
breads and all this but there are people
who profit from avoiding certain sugars
like lactose the milk sugar or fructose
the sugar that is contained in many
vegetables and fruit so this is just a
part of the population but there are
many others who might have
a profit from avoiding coffee of dr.
Stangel what kind of substances from
plans or phytochemicals which you
recommend using instead of antibiotics
well we've seen the most important in
the movie compounds of garlic of radish
of mustard of honey and there are
probably a lot of others and this field
is rapidly emerging and we learn not
about their antibiotic capacities and at
the moment we don't have the idea that
there are any resistances but of course
we've thought this in medicine many
times and we're wrong only other other
advantages for taking plans as
antibiotics well of course you can use
this with your normal food like it has
been very common featured to take like a
radish with fish and I think this this
was done intuitive lived because it
makes you more resistant against the
contamination of bacteria on the fish so
can I just go out in the garden and get
my own antibiotics from from a garden or
do we have to get dry like if you if you
have certain infections of our upper
Airways or the urine attract that are
not complicated you can try this of
course and at the moment we have some
drugs that contain calm parts of radish
and mustard I find it really really
complicated to maintain a healthy
balanced diet you need to be an expert
to do so so isn't it easier just to go
into the pharmacy and get some M
supplements well this is of course
heavily debated and there are tendencies
in the Western countries that many
people help the young people take these
additives all the time I'm very critical
about this and I think that we have
sufficient resources in nature in the
food that is delivered by nature to get
enough supplier to maintain or health
okay what about the apple a day does it
really keep the doctor away ah well
there's been contradictory evidence
about this very interesting questions
because you always have to exclude
confounders which is very hard if the
apple is only symbolic for
a healthy lifestyle then it's true but
if you make the effort just count the
amount of efforts that one consumes and
that has ordinary lifestyle it doesn't
matter much how many efforts you consume
and what is your personal tip for
healthy nutrition or for a home remedy
out of nutrition what's your personal
well red variety I think is the basic
principle and nature is so rich all over
the world and conditions in Asia are
different from Africa and Europe and you
find healthy food everywhere variety
fresh vegetables and fresh fruit and of
course interesting modes of cooking of
adding spices all this is very important
in our daily life okay thank you dr.
Stanga for being with us in the studio
thank you
you